moi je me suis fait vacciner je porte
mon masque et c'est pas moi qui
emmerdent les gens déjà d'une aidé au
quesnoy
respecter le choix ça me fait beaucoup
rire moi ça me fait beaucoup rire en
disant que 20 camps quand gendarme bardé
l'allemagne et le panneau parle en
disant qu'ils n'ont plus confiance en
nous mais comment vous voulez que les
français aient confiance quand vous
tenez des discours qui sont parfois
irresponsables pas obligé jean luc
mélenchon pardon excusez moi jean luc
mélenchon il a quand même comparé le
vaccin à des surgelés quand il est allé
voir nos compatriotes d'outre-mer il
allait soutenir des soignants qui
n'était non vaccinés comment voulez vous
que les français aient confiance et
comment voulez-vous que l'école
française et confiance quand on dit a
aujourd'hui un soignant vacciner positif
au co vide si vous ne poussez pas et que
vous n'etes ernier pas vous avez le
droit de continuer à les travailler
parce qu'il ya une pénurie de soignants
parce que nous nous étions dans la rue
avec les soignants avant la pandémie
pour demander des moyens humains et
financiers et que la république en
marche a préféré les gaz et où les tiré
par les cheveux non première c'est un
vrai c'est pas bien ça me travaillait il
ya une chose que l'oignon qui n'est pas
vacciné qui accepterait de se faire
tester tous les 24 ou les 48 heures en
étant protégé par tous ceux dont les
soignants pourquoi est-ce qu'on
n'accepterait pas qu'ils aient continué
à aller travailler dans des territoires
qui sont mes dents dans des dents avec
des états de sous-investissement les
siennes de santé absolument incroyable
et juste rappelez-vous parce que on a un
petit peu tendance avec les antilles et
à dire c'est loin bon alors il dit ils
veulent pas obéir et cetera rappelez
vous toujours que aux antilles et
notamment en guadeloupe vous n'avez pas
d'eau pour vous là pour vous laver les
mains qui est quand même le premier des
gestes barrières moi j'ai vu des femmes
qui ont de l'eau une fois par jour ou
d'accords avec
des années 70 80 jugent trop formaté
d'asie ont eu du chlordécone non mais
juge foisonnent les corps les eaux et
lecce brayons j'aimerais bien lui fasse
assez lent mais justement
guy lagarde en a parlé avec l'ancien
président dit j'emmerde les non vaccinés
ça vous choque ou pas mais bien sûr tout
est où se trouvait au contraire on est
ce qu'au contraire vous adhérez parce
que il ya un sondage qui est sorti il ya
50 % des gens et qui ont adhéré à la
phrase d'emmanuel bakary koné qu'ils
étaient d'accord avec lui et 50 des gens
qui sont effectivement dans une
complexité de tous les jours qu'ils
disent mais on en a marre et moi je
rejoins voulant rejoindre t il rejoindre
une autre est la question les français
en tout cas personnellement moi j'en ai
marre du politiquement correct je veux
qu'on me parle comme je parle
habituellement tous les jours et le
président l'a fait les gens le savent
simplement aujourd'hui les jeunes quand
ils se voient imposer des contraintes
sanitaires le masque à paris parce que
je suis étudiant à paris quand on n'a
plus le droit d'aller en boîte de nuit
quand on on ne peut plus aller faire la
queue devant la l'aide alimentaire à ce
que je sache je suis allé me
demande si je suis d'accord avec lequel
manuel macouin dit je vous dis que oui
je suis d'accord parce que nous les
jeunes on a fait des contraintes et
quand je vois qu'on a encore une partie
de la population qui sont réfractaires
et qui se permettent de s'affranchir de
ses libertés moi vraiment ça me suis
jamais autant de ces chiffres me révolte
on a des cas qu'on n'a jamais eue enfin
je viens il ya des centaines de mille
cas par jour on est encore à 170
aujourd'hui jordan parent d'élève vous
savez très bien que l'augmentation des
cas elle est due au fait que les gens
sont tous à 10 14 hockey pourrait être
l'adage encadrait avant les vacances de
noël